TRANS. COMMITTEE IN 2024. SO
ITEM NUMBER ONE JUST TO CLARIFY
SP 397 HAS BEEN PULLED BY
SENATOR WAHAB, SO WE ONLY HAVE
TWO BILLS UP TODAY AND, OF
COURSE, A NUMBER OF MEMBERS ARE
IN AND OUT OF VARIOUS
COMMITTEES. AS WE HAVE A FIERCE
DEADLINE THIS THIS WEEK, SO
WE'RE GOING TO START OFF WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO. WHICH IS A
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR. GO RIGHT
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CAN
WE TURN ON THE MIC? FOR SENATOR
BLAKE SPIRIT. THANK YOU. OKAY
WELL, THANK YOU. I'M HAPPY TO BE
HERE. UM MY NAME IS SENATOR
CATHERINE BLAKE SPEAR. AND I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU TODAY.
SB 689. THIS BILL WILL REDUCE
UNNECESSARY DELAYS IN THE
BUILDING OF BIKE LANES ALONG
CALIFORNIA'S COASTLINE AND
ALREADY DEVELOPED AREAS DURING
MY TIME. AS THE MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF ENCINITAS, WE BUILT
SEVERAL PROTECTED BIKE LANE
PROJECTS. AMENDING THE LOCAL
COASTAL PROGRAM, OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS THE LCP AND COMMISSIONING THE
REQUIRED ADDITIONAL TRAFFIC
STUDIES RESULTED IN A DIFFICULT,
EXPENSIVE TIME CONSUMING AND AT
TIMES NEEDLESSLY CONTENTIOUS
PROCESS FOR BUILDING A BIKE
LANE, MAKING BIKING EASIER,
SAFER AND MORE COMMON IS A
CRITICAL ELEMENT AND REDUCING
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AS
WE CONFRONT THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US AS
POLICYMAKERS TO ENSURE GOOD
GOVERNANCE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND ELIMINATE ANY BUREAUCRATIC
HURDLES THAT MAY PREVENT OR
PROLONGED PROJECTS THAT PROVIDE
A NET POSITIVE TO SOCIETY AND
OUR ENVIRONMENT. MY TEAM AND I
HAVE HAD PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION OVER MORE THAN A YEAR
ABOUT THIS EFFORT, AND I THANK
THEM VERY MUCH FOR THEIR
ENGAGEMENT WITH MY OFFICE. WE
ARE NOW ON THE SAME PAGE ABOUT
HOW TO ACHIEVE THIS OBJECTIVE.
THIS BILL DOES TWO THINGS. FIRST
IT STATES THAT A NEW TRAFFIC
STUDY, WHICH CAN BE COSTLY AND
TIME CONSUMING IS NOT NECESSARY
FOR AN LCP AMENDMENT WHEN A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS CONVERTING
AN EXISTING MOTORIZED VEHICLE
AND INTO A DEDICATED BICYCLE
LANE. SECONDLY, IT ALLOWS FOR
THE AMENDMENT TO THE LCP TO BE
PROCESSED UNDER A DIM MINIMUS
EXEMPTION WHEN THE COASTAL
COMMISSION'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
DETERMINES THAT THIS IS
WARRANTED. SB 689 IS A GOOD
GOVERNANCE BILL THAT WILL
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY AND
RESPONSIVENESS OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION IN THE CONSTRUCTION
OF BIKE LANES WITH ME TODAY I AM
HAPPY TO HAVE MORE RETIRED FROM
TOP STRATEGIES AND SHE'S HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT, WELCOME,
THANK YOU. YOU CAN COME RIGHT UP
HERE TO THE TABLE. IF YOU'D
LIKE. WE'RE DOING THINGS A
LITTLE DIFFERENTLY.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE A
REMOTE TESTIMONY ANYMORE, BUT
WE'LL MAKE SURE YOUR VERY
WELCOME. HERE. MISS TOP. THANK
YOU. THANKS. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I AM WE WERE
TOP HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO. HAPPY TO BE THE
SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE BEFORE
YOU. SP 689 IS INTENDED TO
REDUCE UNNECESSARY DELAYS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SUSTAINABLE
BICYCLE SAFETY TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS ALONG CALIFORNIA'S
COAST. THIS BILL WOULD MAINTAIN
IMPORTANT COASTAL PROTECTIONS
AND ENSURE BROAD COASTAL ACCESS,
BUT REPLACES THE CURRENT
BURDENSOME PROCESS AND TIME
CONSUMING COASTAL COMMISSION
PROCESS WITH ONE THAT IS
STREAMLINED IN PURPOSEFUL THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
HAS BEGUN TO MANDATE THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AMEND THEIR LOCAL
COASTAL PROGRAMS FOR PROJECTS
THAT MERELY RE STRIPE THE ROAD
FOR CONGESTION REDUCTION,
PRODUCT PROJECT PURPOSES, AND
LCP AMENDMENT PROCESS CAN TAKE
UP TO 18 MONTHS OR EVEN TWO
YEARS TO COMPLETE AND, OF
COURSE, COST CITY RESOURCES.
THESE RESTRICTING PROJECTS DO
NOT EXTEND BEHIND BEYOND THE
CURRENT RIGHT OF WAY. OR HAVE
ANY IMPACT ON SURROUNDING FLORA
OR FAUNA. IMPROVING OUR BIKE
LANE NETWORK, ESPECIALLY ALONG
THE CURVED COASTAL ROADS WILL
ALSO LEAD TO BETTER BIKE SAFETY
AND LIKELY RESULT IN FEWER
FATALITIES ALONG OUR COASTAL
ROADS. SP 689 IS INTENDED TO
REDUCE THE UNNECESSARY, COSTLY
AND TIME CONSUMING BUREAUCRATIC
HURDLES, WHICH HAVE PREVENTED
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS LIKE THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO. TO PURSUE
COMMON SENSE TRAFFIC
IMPROVEMENTS. THE MEASURE WILL
IMPROVE SAFETY FOR ALL MODES AND
ASSISTANT MEETING OUR CLIMATE
AND TRAFFIC SAFETY GOALS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
BELIEVE YOU ALSO HAVE CIRCULATE
SAN DIEGO. I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'RE HERE TODAY. I DON'T KNOW
THEY'RE NOT HERE. IT'S JUST YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU. SO MUCH FOR
TESTIMONY NOW WILL BRING FORWARD
OPPOSITION LIVABLE CALIFORNIA.
CAN THEY COME FORWARD? ARE THEY
NOT HERE? OKAY? I THINK THEIR
OPPOSITION WAS THERE, NOT ON THE
TELEPHONE TODAY. I THINK THEIR
OPPOSITION WAS FROM THE BILL
FROM LAST YEAR BECAUSE THIS IS A
TWO YEAR BILL. SO IT CHANGED MY
APOLOGIES HERE. WE HAD A
MISTAKE, ALL RIGHT? I DON'T
THINK WE HAVE ALL SUPPORT, WHICH
IS FANTASTIC. OKAY SO ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SB
SUCCEEDING NINE OR OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD FROM THE
BROOM. OKAY? THANK YOU AND
ORGANIZATION, PLEASE. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM. TURN
MEMBERS. I'M SEAN DRAKE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION.
THE COMMISSION DOESN'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE
LEGISLATION, BUT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR'S
COLLABORATION ON THIS LANGUAGE.
AND I'M JUST AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ETHAN NAGLER. I'M HALF OF THE
CITY OF CARLSBAD IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO COME FORWARD AND SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION? OKAY SEE NONE. SO
WE'LL TAKE IT BACK TO THE
DIOCESE. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS? COMMENTS SENATOR
ARCHULETTA. UM CONGRATULATIONS
TO THE COASTAL CITY OF SAN DIEGO
. AND SO ON. I'M JUST WONDERING
IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ELAINE.
THAT'S GOING TO BE REDUCED,
ELIMINATED AND THE BIKE LANE
WILL TAKE ITS PLACE AND HOW MANY
BICYCLE WHAT WOULD YOU USE? I
MEAN, HOW MANY PEOPLE WILL
UTILIZE THAT. SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION. SO A CITY LOOKS
AT ITS WHOLE ROAD NETWORK AND
WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO IMPLEMENT
THEIR BICYCLE MASTER PLAN OR THE
OTHER PLANNING DOCUMENTS,
SOMETIMES THERE ARE ROADS THAT
HAVE TWO LANES IN BOTH
DIRECTIONS. BUT THE ROAD DOESN'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY THAT THEY
REALLY NEED TO HAVE THAT OTHER
LANE. AND SO THERE ARE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT IN ORDER TO FOR
A CITY TO MAKE THAT DECISION,
YOU KNOW, THOSE ARE LOCAL
ELECTED PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE TO PUT THE
BIKE NETWORK, THE BICYCLE LANE
NETWORK. UM IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
MAKE THOSE CHANGES THEY WERE
HAVING TO GO THROUGH THIS REALLY
TIME CONSUMING AND COSTLY
PROCESS, SO IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
CITY WILL BE DIFFERENT. HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE USING THAT BIKE LANE
AND ALSO WHAT TYPE OF BIKE LANE
IS IT? BARRIER PROTECTED. IS IT
JUST PAINT? WHAT ARE THE WHAT'S
THE CONFIGURATION OF PARKING
WITH BIKE LANE WITH TRAVELING,
BUT THESE ARE DECISIONS THAT ARE
BEING MADE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
ALREADY. IT'S JUST THAT ONCE
THEY BECOME MADE THEN THERE IS
THIS MULTIYEAR, EXPENSIVE
PROCESS AND WHAT THAT ALSO DOES
IS IN IT AND INSIGHTS ALMOST
MORE CONTROVERSY OVER BIKE LANE
PROJECTS BECAUSE IF YOU CAN MAKE
PROGRAMMATIC DECISIONS AT A HIGH
LEVEL OF WHERE DO WE WANT OUR
BIKE NETWORK TO BE, BUT THEN, AT
EVERY INDIVIDUAL STAGE, YOU NEED
TO HAVE ANOTHER HEARING TO TALK
ABOUT WHETHER THE BIKE STUDY OR
THE TRAFFIC STUDY IS ACCEPTED.
IT'S JUST IT'S NEEDLESS AND SO
LUCKILY, OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE COASTAL COMMISSION HAVE
RESULTED IN A SHARED
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE FACT
THAT IT NEEDS TO BE EASIER TO
GET THROUGH THAT PART OF THE
PROCESS WELL AS A FORMER MAYOR
AND COUNCIL MEMBER IN MY CITY,
YOU KNOW, WE ALWAYS ASK
SACRAMENTO GIVE US BACK THE
BALL. LET US GOVERNOR SELVES
2 DEGREES AND I THINK THIS IS
SHOWING THE JOINT VENTURE
BETWEEN SACRAMENTO AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND I COULD SEE THAT
BECAUSE IF EACH COMMUNITY ALONG
THE COAST WILL BE ABLE TO DECIDE
AMONG THEMSELVES, AND IT'S
CERTAINLY MAKE IT A LOT, UH MORE
FINANCING FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE
BECAUSE NOW IT'S ONLY PAINTING
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RIGHT AND NO
CONSTRUCTION, SO I THINK IT'S A
GOOD ONE, AND I'LL MOVE IT WHEN
IT'S APPROPRIATE. SOUNDS GREAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DOT AYE. MAYBE THIS IS JUST
EARLY. UH FRUSTRATION. I CAN'T
EVEN BELIEVE YOU NEED TO HAVE
THE COASTAL COMMISSION'S
APPROVAL FOR SOMETHING LIKE THIS
IN THE FIRST PLACE, BUT THAT'S
THE WAY IT IS. YES, I MEAN, I'LL
JUST SHARE THAT. AS A MAYOR OF A
COASTAL CITY. WE WOULD TRY TO
DESIGN OUR ENTIRE BIKE LANE
AROUND AVOIDING THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. SO SAYING, HOW CAN
WE NOT EVEN TAKE OUT ONE PARKING
SPOT? OR HOW CAN WE REPLACE HAVE
THE BIKE LANE FIT WITHIN A LANE?
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE FOR
PEDESTRIANS? BECAUSE WE CAN ALL
WE NEED TO LEAVE THE TRAVEL
LINES AS THEY ARE SOME OF THESE
THINGS THAT CONTORTIONS TO AVOID
THAT REGULATORY BURDEN, AND ALSO
THE DELAY. UM REALLY, IT'S
SUBSTANTIAL. IT HAS A
SUBSTANTIAL EFFECT ON WHAT
HAPPENS IN COASTAL CITIES.
THAT'S REALLY QUITE PROBLEMATIC.
AND SO I'M HAPPY THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO WORK WITH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION BECAUSE THEIR INITIAL
CONCERNS WERE ABOUT FLORA AND
FAUNA AND OTHER THINGS THAT
REALLY AREN'T IMPLICATED BECAUSE
THIS IS ALREADY A DEVELOPED
AREA, SO THESE ARE ALREADY
CARRYING PEOPLE. IT'S JUST A
QUESTION OF WHAT IS THE LOCAL
CITY. WANT IN TERMS OF THE
DIFFERENT ACTUALLY BUILT
ENVIRONMENT INFRASTRUCTURE.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK, VICE CHAIR
NILO. THANK YOU THE WITH REGARD
TO SENATOR ARCHER LATEST,
ARCHULETA IS QUESTION. I THINK
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW THE ANSWER
TO IT. YOU STATE THAT SAN DIEGO.
AH KNOWS THAT THE ROAD IS
UNDERUTILIZED, BUT THERE HASN'T
BEEN A TRAFFIC STUDY AND NOR
WOULD ONE BE REQUIRED, AND WE'RE
REALLY NOT TALKING ABOUT JUST
THIS ONE ROAD. WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS AUTHORIZING IT MORE BROADLY,
I WOULD AGREE. THAT THE PROCESS
GOING THROUGH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION IS BURDENSOME, AND I
WOULD AGREE THAT IT WOULD BE
BETTER TO TRY TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT. BUT I WOULDN'T AGREE
THAT THERE SHOULD BE NO TRAFFIC
ANALYSIS BECAUSE YOU REALLY
CAN'T TELL HOW TRAFFIC MIGHT
ALONG THAT ROAD MIGHT BE
DISPLACED. MANY TIMES, I HEAR,
UH, I WAS TELLING. MRS TOP ABOUT
THIS YESTERDAY WHEN I WAS IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THERE WAS A
PROPOSAL THAT THE AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT TO RESTRICT
TRAFFIC LANE AND MAKE IT A BIKE
LANE AND THAT THERE WOULD BE NO
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF THAT
BECAUSE PEOPLE WOULD DRIVE THERE
WOULD JUST RIDE THE BIKE. AND I
MEAN, HONEST TO GOD. THAT WAS
THE CONVERSATION AND SOMETIMES
MAYBE THAT TAKES THE
CONVERSATION OVER A BIT WITH
SOME PEOPLE, BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS, THERE'S CURRENTLY
TRAFFIC. ON A FOUR LANE ROAD
THAT'S GOING TO BE RESTRICTED
WITH ONLY ONE LANE ON EACH SIDE
AT THIS POINT, AND WE REALLY
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE
IMPACT OF THAT'S GOING TO BE.
BUT EVEN IF YOU DO HEAR IF WE
PASS THIS BILL, WE'RE
AUTHORIZING THIS FOR ALL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NOT TO BE ANSWERABLE
TO A HIGHER POWER. BUT NOT EVEN
HAVE TO DO A TRAFFIC STUDY JUST
TO CLARIFY SO TRAFFIC STUDIES
ARE ALREADY REQUIRED SO THERE
WOULD HAVE ALREADY BEEN A
TRAFFIC STUDY DONE. THE ISSUE IS
WHEN THERE IS THIS LCP AMENDMENT
THAT IS HAPPENING BECAUSE OF A
BIKE LANE PROJECT DOES A NEW
TRAFFIC STUDY NEEDS TO BE DONE?
AND SO IT'S NOT WORTH THIS ISN'T
THE WILD WEST? I MEAN, THE ROAD
NETWORK IS HEAVILY REGULATED,
MANAGED AND WELL UNDERSTOOD. SO
WHETHER ROAD HAS HIGH VOLUMES OF
TRAFFIC OR NOT. THING THAT WILL
ALREADY THAT THERE WILL ALREADY
BE AVAILABLE AS DATA. IT'S THIS
IS JUST ADDITIONAL STUDIES, AND
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO SAY
ANYTHING MORE. I THINK IT'S
EXACTLY IT'S THROUGH THE CHAIR
IF I COULD, UM, TRAFFIC STUDIES
ARE DONE IN MYRIAD WAYS. THEY'RE
DONE THROUGH OUR BICYCLE
TRANSPORTATION PLAN. MOST OF
THESE PROJECTS ARE ALSO BOUND BY
SEQUA. AND SO THERE ARE
DEFINITELY THE TYPES OF TRAFFIC
IMPACT STUDIES THAT I THINK
YOU'RE REFERRING TO ARE TAKING
PLACE. WHAT HAPPENED AT THE
COASTAL COMMISSION IS THAT EVEN
THOUGH THERE WAS NO STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT FOR A TRAFFIC STUDY,
OVER TIME STAFF HAD BEEN
REQUIRING AS TRAFFIC IMPACT
STUDY TO THE TO THE SENATORS
POINT. AND SO THIS WAS SIMPLY TO
CLARIFY FOR THE SIMPLER PROJECTS
. WE DON'T NEED TO HAVE YET
ANOTHER TRAFFIC IMPACT STUDY
PERFORMED FOR THE COASTAL
COMMISSION, BUT THEY ARE STILL
PERFORMED IN OTHER VENUES AND
APPROPRIATELY SO. THAT BEFORE
WITH WITH REGARD TO THIS
PARTICULAR ROAD, I SUPPOSE
THAT'S TRUE. BUT MY READING OF
THE BILL IS THAT IN ANY OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCE, THIS BILL WOULD BE
AUTHORIZING A JURISDICTION TO GO
FORWARD WITH THE PROJECT LIKE
THIS WITHOUT TRAFFIC STUDY, AND
IF THERE IS AN EXISTING TRAFFIC
STUDY, WHO KNOWS HOW OLD IT IS?
AND IT VERY WELL COULD NEED TO
BE UPDATED. BUT UNDER THIS BILL,
IT WOULDN'T HAVE TO BE. YEAH I
MEAN, THIS DOES REALLY GO TO THE
QUESTION OF WHO HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY AND THE
JURISDICTION TO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT BARRY LOCAL ROADS. I MEAN,
WE HAVE DELEGATED THAT TO LOCAL
CITIES AND THEIR CITY COUNCILS
WHO ARE RESPONSIVE TO THE LOCAL
POPULATION THAT HAS A VERY
STRONG OPINION ABOUT DRIVING.
AND SO I THINK THAT THE ISSUE OF
DO WE WANT A COASTAL COMMISSION
TO BE THE ONE THAT'S SAYING
ACTUALLY, WE WANT THE TRAFFIC
STUDY. THAT TELLS US WHAT WHAT
ARE THE PEAK TIMES OF TRAVEL ON
THIS ROAD? ARE WE GOING TO GET
INVOLVED IN THE ROAD NETWORK TO
THE DEGREE THAT WERE SAYING THAT
YOU CAN OR CAN'T HAVE A BIKE
LANE BASED ON SOME PARTICULAR
PEAK NUMBER OF BICYCLES OR CARS
AT A CERTAIN TIME? AND I MEAN IN
GENERAL. THE CRITICISM AND
CONCERN ABOUT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION IS OVERREACH. THE
ISSUE OF WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THE COAST. IT'S A
PUBLIC GOOD, BUT HOW MUCH ARE
THEY RESPONSIBLE FOR TELLING
CITIES HOW THEY CAN ADAPT?
WRAPPED THE CITY THEIR CITIES AS
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGHT. CLIMATE
CHANGE AND ALSO SEA LEVEL RISE
AND OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY COASTAL. SO I MEAN
TO ME THE FACT THAT THE COASTAL
MISSION ACTUALLY AGREES WITH
THIS IS A GREAT, UH, RECOGNITION
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE CHANGED
AND THAT ALSO OVER TIME, THERE'S
BEEN A CREEP OF WHAT IS
CONSIDERED ACCEPTABLE IN THE
COASTAL COMMISSION ESSENTIALLY
CAN ASK FOR NEARLY ANYTHING
BECAUSE THE CITY WANTS TO DO IT
OR THE DEVELOPER WANTS TO DO IT.
AND SO THIS IS JUST LIMITING
BACK A LITTLE BIT. WHAT WHAT IS
POSSIBLE TO BE ASKED FOR THANK
YOU, VICE CHAIR, NILO. AND
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
SENATOR, WE HAVE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. SO, MADAM SECRETARY, CAN
YOU ESTABLISH FORM FOR US,
PLEASE? SENATOR IS GONZALEZ HERE
? GONZALEZ HERE. NILO HERE, ALAN
ALAN. HERE ARCHULETTA HERE.
BECKER. SHAKESPEARE. HERE HERE
HERE AT CORTES E. DALLI DALLI
HERE, DODD DOT HERE, LEMON ON
HERE. NEWMAN WHEN? WHEN? HERE
CIERTO HAMBURG. WUHAN. HERE
HERE. OKAY WE'VE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM. THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT,
WE'LL MOVE ON TO SENATOR DELI
REAL QUICK. I SAW THIS EARLIER
TODAY AND HAD A QUESTION. SO
WHEN YOU'RE REDUCING LANES, SO
THE COASTAL COMMISSION YOU HAVE
ONE CITY AND THEN THE NEXT CITY
IS RIGHT THERE AND CAN FLOW OF
TRAFFIC IS CRITICAL TO. ACTUALLY
I THINK THE COASTAL COMMISSION'S
GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
WORKS WELL TO AN IMPACT THAT
THEIR PLACE SO WHEN YOU RE
STRIPING TO REDUCE LANES, THERE
SHOULD IS A TRAFFIC STUDY THE
SAME THERE. LIKE SENATOR NEELA
WAS BRINGING UP I MEAN, I THINK
THE EXAMPLE THAT THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO HAD THEY WEREN'T EVEN
ACTUALLY REDUCING A TRAFFIC
LANE. THEY WERE JUST TRYING TO
BUILD A PROTECTED BIKE LANE AND
THEY HAD ALREADY MADE THE
DECISION ALLOCATED THE MONEY AND
IN THE PROCESS OF GOING THROUGH
THIS LONG PROCESS, THERE WAS AN
ACCIDENT WHERE SOMEONE WAS
SERIOUSLY INJURED. AND YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF HAND WRINGING
OVER THAT. LIKE HOW CAN WE
COULDN'T GET THIS BUILT FASTER?
BUT WHAT IS WRONG WITH THINGS
WHEN WE HAVE ALREADY DECIDED TO
BUILD IT AND ARE AND BUT WE
CAN'T GET THROUGH THE PROCESS.
SO SO I THINK YOU KNOW THE
REALITY IS THAT CITIES ARE
MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT THE TYPES
OF THEIR THE TRANSPORTATION
ELEMENT IN ANY GENERAL PLAN FOR
A CITY IS SOMETHING THAT IS
DEBATED AND DECIDED LOCALLY AND
ALSO COGS. I'M ASSUMING IN AKAGI
THAT YEAH, AND TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION AROUND THEM,
RIGHT. EXCUSE ME. I DON'T MEAN
TO INTERRUPT, YOU KNOW, THAT'S
ONE OF MY I MEAN, WE HAVE THANK
YOU IN MY AREA WE HAVE SAY,
WHICH IS SACRAMENTO
TRANSPORTATION, RIGHT? AND
THAT'S ROSEVILLE. ALL THE
CLOTHES. YOU HAVE THE SAME THING
ON THE COAST SO THAT DOES THAT
PLAY INTO THIS ABILITY AS WELL
AS THAT ONE CITY TRYING TO JUST
CARVED THEIR WAY OUT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. YOU RAISING RAISING
EXACTLY THE POINT OF WHY WE'RE
HERE TODAY, AND THAT IS BECAUSE
NOT ONLY WITHIN THE REGION, BUT
WITHIN THE CITY. WE HAVE WE HAVE
A NETWORK THAT NEEDS TO MAKE
SENSE TOGETHER, AND WHAT WE
FOUND IS THAT WE HAVE A NETWORK
THAT AS SOON AS YOU HIT THE
COASTAL ZONE IT. ALL THE RULES
HAVE CHANGED, AND WE CAN'T MAKE
THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE, SO WE DON'T HAVE A QUICK,
QUICK, COHESIVE NETWORK. AND
THEN WHEN YOU BROADEN IT OUT
EVEN FURTHER WITHIN THE FULL
COUNTY, WE RUN INTO AN EVEN
LARGER PROBLEM. BUT YES, YES, WE
ARE HERE SO THAT THE PROCESS TO
MAKE THOSE MAKE THAT CONTINUITY.
TAKE PLACE AND OCCUR IS EASIER
FASTER AND MAKES SENSE.
OTHERWISE WHEN WE HAVE THESE
MULTI YEAR DELAYS WELL, CARLSBAD
COULD GO MOVE FORWARD WITH THEIR
PROJECT WHILE WE YOU KNOW,
CONTINUE TO HIM AND HAN OURS,
AND SO THEN THEY DON'T END UP
ACTUALLY CREATING A COHESIVE
NETWORK. SO THAT REALLY KIND OF
HIT ON EXACTLY WHAT BROUGHT US
HERE AND I'LL JUST ADD THAT SHE
REPRESENTS THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
, WHICH HAS PARTS OF THE CITY
THAT ARE IN THE COASTAL ZONE AND
SUBJECT TO THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AND OTHERS THAT
AREN'T SO THEY ARE DEALING EVERY
DAY WITH THAT DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
A PROJECT HERE ON THIS SIDE OF
THE ROAD VERSUS THAT SIDE OF THE
ROAD, SO IT'S A IT'S A REALLY
GOOD DATA POINT ABOUT THE
DIFFICULTIES. THANK YOU. OKAY
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS? COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS. OKAY SEE NONE. AND
WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
ARCHULETTA. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. SENATOR ARCHULETTA HAS
MOTIONED. SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE THE ROLE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SP 689. THE MOTION IS
DUE PAST SENATORS GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ, I NILO NO, NO, NO ALAN
ARCHULETTA BECKER. SPIRIT THANKS
FOR YOUR EYE, CORTESI. DOLLY!
DON DOT I LIMÓN NEWMAN THIS
MORNING WHEN CIERTO HAMBURG.
WHAT HARM. OKAY 6 TO 16 TO 1
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, AND WE'RE
WAITING FOR OUR NEXT AUTHOR,
SENATOR GLASER, WHO I BELIEVE IS
STILL CHEERING ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW, SO WE'LL
TAKE A SHORT RECESS AND WE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK. THANK YOU.
COMMERCIAL BREAK.
SO YOU'RE GOING TO PRESENT NOW
ON SB 8 TO 7. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IS THIS WORKING? YES. MAYBE
MAYBE NOT. OKAY? UM. FIRST I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR HER
WORK WITH ME AND STAKEHOLDERS ON
THIS BILL. WE HAD A ROBUST
DEBATE LAST YEAR AS YOU MAY
RECALL ON THIS ISSUE AND TAKEN
THE TIME TO TRY TO RECONCILE THE
DIFFERENT VIEWS AND I THINK,
COME UP WITH A PATH AND
HOPEFULLY YOU'LL FIND
SATISFACTORY TODAY. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THAT THE STAFF MR CHEN
FOR REALLY PREPARING AN
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS. I HOPE
EVERYONE'S HAD THE CHANCE TO
READ IT. ANYONE LISTENING TO MY
VOICE AND WANT TO KNOW THE
HISTORY OF THIS ISSUE? IT REALLY
IS EXCEPTIONAL FOR TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT ALL THE DIFFERENT
OPINIONS THAT HAVE COME BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE OVER THE COURSE
OF A NUMBER OF YEARS. AND ONE
THING THAT'S NO WORTHY IN THE
ANALYSIS IS THAT UM IN MANY WAYS
, THERE'S THE PROVERBIAL
QUESTION YOU'VE HEARD FROM ME,
WHICH IS WHY DO WE NEED A STATE
LAW? CAN'T WE WORK THIS THING
OUT LOCALLY, AND THERE HAS BEEN
EFFORTS IN THIS SPACE TO TRY TO
WORK THIS THING OUT LOCALLY, AND
IN THIS ANALYSIS, IT TALKS ABOUT
THE BART BOARD AND THEIR
DELIBERATIONS ON THE CHARTER FOR
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL OF BART.
GOING BACK TO 2022. AND SO IT'S
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS, AND IT'S
A CONTINUING EFFORT TO TRY TO
FIND COMMON GROUND IN THE WORK
OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL. SO THE
BILL THAT'S BEFORE YOU TODAY IN
SOME WAYS SIMILAR IN SOME WAYS
DIFFERENT. LET ME GO THROUGH
THAT WITH YOU. IT'S SIMILAR IN
THAT IT APPLIES THE EXISTING
STATUTORY AUTHORITY THAT WE HAVE
FOR OUR DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION'S INSPECTOR
GENERAL. AND APPLIES THAT TO THE
BART INSPECTOR GENERAL. SO THAT
FRAMEWORK OF TAKING WHAT WE HAVE
DETERMINED ARE APPROPRIATE
POWERS AND AUTHORITIES FOR OUR
STATE I G. APPLIES TO THE. THE
BART I G. SPECIFICALLY IT
PROVIDES THE BAR INSPECTOR
GENERAL WITH EXPLICIT ACCESS TO
RECORDS AND PROPERTY RECORDS AND
PROPERTY AND ACCESS TO
CONFIDENTIAL RECORDS UNLESS
STATE LAW EXPLICITLY PRECLUDES
ACCESS. DON'T WANT TO DO
ANYTHING THAT INTERFERES WITH
THAT. NOW IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE CHAIR AND WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
I AM PROPOSING A COUPLE CHANGES
UNDER THE EXISTING STATUTORY
AUTHORITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION'S INSPECTOR
GENERAL. CRIMINAL PENALTIES ARE
IN PLAY IF YOU DON'T COOPERATE
IN THE APPROPRIATE WAY I AM
TAKING OUT OF THIS BILL.
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
DISTRIBUTED TO YOU, ALTHOUGH WE
CAN'T DO IT HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE PROPOSAL TO TAKE OUT
THE CRIMINAL PENALTY ELEMENT IN
MY TESTIMONY LAST YEAR, I
INDICATED I WAS WILLING TO DO
THAT AS WELL BUT WANTED TO
CONSULT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT WOULDN'T
JEOPARDIZE THE PASSAGE OF THE
BILL. ULTIMATE PASSAGE OF THE
BILL. I MENTIONED AT THE TIME
THAT IN MY BILL IN 2022, I DID
NOT HAVE CRIMINAL PENALTIES AS A
AS A AS A POWER TO THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL. BUT THERE WAS SUBPOENA
POWER. SO IF SOMEONE WASN'T
COOPERATING, THERE'D BE A WAY TO
HAVE THEM COME FORWARD AND AT
LEAST GET THEIR TESTIMONY IN THE
INVESTIGATION THAT WAS BEING
UNDERTAKEN. SO WHILE I AM
REMOVING IN THE AND THESE
AMENDMENTS, THE CRIMINAL
PENALTIES I HAVE SPOKEN WITH
STAKEHOLDERS, THE CHAIR AND
OTHERS THAT I DO WHAT WE DO NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE CAN DO
THEIR WORK AND WHETHER SUBPOENA
POWER IS THE AVENUE. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO EXPLORE. IF IN YOUR
WISDOM THIS BILL DOES MOVE
FORWARD TODAY. AND SECONDLY, I
AM PROPOSING AN AMENDMENT AGAIN.
WE CAN'T TAKE IT HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE THAT WILL HAPPEN AS IF
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD TO
SPECIFY THAT, IF ANYONE WHO IS
SUBJECT TO AN INVESTIGATION, AN
EMPLOYEE WHO IS SUBJECT TO AN
INVESTIGATION OR MAY BE SUBJECT
TO DISCIPLINE OR ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCES AS A PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION THAT THEY WOULD BE
AFFORDED WEINGARTEN RIGHTS. AND
THAT SIMPLY MEANS THAT THAT
BEFORE THAT INTERVIEW TAKES
PLACE THAT THEY'D BE INFORMED
THAT THEY COULD HAVE
REPRESENTATION FROM THE UNION TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT IN THAT
INQUIRY, AND I DON'T HAVE ANY
TROUBLE WITH THAT AMENDMENT. IN
FACT, IT WAS AN AMENDMENT THAT I
TOOK IN MY LEGISLATION IN 2022,
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S ALSO
BEING ADDED. BUT I JUST WOULDN'T
WANT TO NOTE THAT THIS IS AN
ONGOING WORK IF DISCUSSION THAT
IS, IT'S MY HOPE THAT THE BART
BOARD AND THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN BART ARE
CONTINUING TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT A CHARTER
FOR THE I G. I WOULD SAY FOR NOW
FOR YEARS HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
RESOLVE AND IT'S CERTAINLY OUR
HOPE THAT THAT WORK WILL
CONTINUE AND WILL GIVE US
OPTIMISM AS IF THIS BILL DOES
MOVE FORWARD ABOUT HOW IT SHOULD
BE CRAFTED OR NOT. TO BE
DETERMINED. AND FINALLY, MEMBERS
, UM WHEN THE BAY AREA VOTERS
CREATED THE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL, UH, THEY CERTAINLY
ANTICIPATED THAT THAT WOULD BE
AN OFFICE THAT COULD DO THEIR
WORK HAVE ACCESS TO EMPLOYEES
HAVE ACCESS TO RECORDS AND TO BE
ABLE TO DO WHAT EVERY INSPECTOR
GENERAL AND PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE
ABLE TO DO. THIS BILL DOES
PROVIDE THE COMMON TOOLS IN THAT
SPACE TO ALLOW THEM TO DO THAT
WORK. AND WITH THAT AGAIN WOULD
THANKS TO THE CHAIR TO THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO I'VE MET WITH.
AND TO ALL OF YOU WHO HAVE GIVEN
ME YOUR FEEDBACK ON THIS
MEASURE. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY AND ASKED
FOR AN I VOTE. RIGHT? THANK YOU
SO MUCH, SENATOR GLACIER AND I
DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL
OF YOUR STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS ON
THIS ISSUE THAT I KNOW IS VERY,
VERY IMPORTANT TO YOU. SO THANK
YOU FOR LINING UP ALL OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS. THOSE WILL BE TAKEN
IN APPROPRIATIONS DUE TO THE
TIMING AND AS MENTIONED, THEY
ARE IN SECTIONS TO BE, WHICH
ADDRESSED THE WEINGARTEN RIGHTS
AND SECTION FOUR, WHICH ADDRESS
THE CRIMINAL PENALTIES THAT HAVE
BEEN STRUCK AND ALSO ADDED IN
THERE. ALL RIGHT. SO WITH THAT
WE HAVE SUPPORT HERE. ANY
SUPPORT I BELIEVE YOU HAVE ON
FILE ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AUDITORS. THE AREA
COUNCIL LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
MISSION STREET NEIGHBORS. PLEASE
COME FORWARD. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
DO A FORMAL WITNESS TESTIMONY,
OKAY? COME ON IN. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. ALEX TORRES DIRECTORS
ARE FORMER DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
BARRIER COUNCIL. NOW BROWNSTEIN
HYATT ON BEHALF OF THE BARRIER
COUNCIL, PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL LAST YEAR, WANT TO AGAIN
REITERATE THE COUNCIL'S SUPPORT
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY. REALLY
EXCITED TO SEE THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN HERE? WE THINK IT'S A
COMMON SENSE, COMPROMISE AND
PROUD TO SUPPORT IT AGAIN TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, EVERYONE. CHARLES
WATSON ON BEHALF OF THIS
FRANCISCO BAY AREA, RAPID TRAINS
A DISTRICT OR BART. THANK YOU.
SENATOR FOR YOUR COMMENTS WILL
REVIEW THE LANGUAGE AND
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING
. WE DO HAVE A SUPPORT OF
AMENDED POSITION BASED ON
CHANGING THE PROVISIONS ON
CRIMINALIZATION TO THE SUBPOENA
POWER AS MENTIONED WHICH WE WILL
REVIEW AND FOLLOW UP WITH THE
SENATOR. ALSO HAD CONCERNS ABOUT
THE SCOPE OF WORK OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL WITH THE
OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS FOR BART
AND THE OFFICE OF THE
INDEPENDENT POLICE AUDITOR. BUT
WILL YOU LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORKING WITH
SENATOR? THANK YOU ALL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE WHO'D
LIKE TO COME FORWARD AND SUPPORT
AH NOW WILL TAKE ON OPPOSITION.
ANYONE WHO IS NEUTRAL. IN
BETWEEN WHICH I BELIEVE THESE
TWO GENTLEMEN ARE MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MATT BROUGHT HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION. I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND THE SENATOR FOR
CONVENING US ALL TOGETHER TO
TALK ABOUT A PATH FORWARD FOR
THIS BILL. UM, THAT WE THINK
SORT OF BALANCES THE NEED TO
KEEP THE PRESSURE ON US AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO NEGOTIATE THE
CHARTER AND GOOD FAITH BUT ALSO
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT OUR CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW THE BILL WAS DRAFTED.
HOW IT IMPACTS WORKERS ON THE
GROUND IT, BART. I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT FROM WHAT WE'VE HEARD
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WE'RE ABOUT
90% THERE IN TERMS OF GETTING A
DEAL DONE ON CHARTER REFORM. UH
AND WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT HAPPENS
BEFORE THE FIRST QUARTER THE END
OF THE FIRST QUARTER. AND IF
THAT'S THE CASE, YOU KNOW.
HOPEFULLY THE BILL WILL HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED ITS GOAL OF
BRINGING US ALL TO THE TABLE AND
WE'LL HAVE A PATH FORWARD
WITHOUT A BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS
TERRY BRENNAN ON BEHALF OF STU,
CALIFORNIA, FIRST OF ALL, HAPPY
NEW YEAR AND THE RISK OF
ALIENATING LARRY DAVID, BUT, UH
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THE PARTIES TOGETHER. UM WE
ACTUALLY HAD A COUPLE OF
CONSTRUCTIVE IDEAS. COME OUT OF
THAT MEETING THAT WE HADN'T
THOUGHT OF BEFORE. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON THIS. WE
ARE NOT OPPOSED TO MOVING
FORWARD AND VERY HOPEFUL THAT A
LOCAL AH SOLUTION WILL BE
PROVIDED THIS PROBLEM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
SUPPORT OPPOSITION IN BETWEEN,
PLEASE COME FORWARD IN ROOM
1200. OKAY SEE NONE. SO WE'LL
TAKE IT BACK. WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR. THANK YOU.
UM I APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE ON THIS BILL, AND I
JUST WANTED TO ASK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS BILL AND
THE BILL THAT THE GOVERNOR
VETOED. IS IT THE WINE, GARDNER
WRITES, THAT ARE THE MAIN
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHERE IT IS,
UM CURRENTLY WITH THE PROPOSED
CHANGES AND WHERE IT WAS WHEN HE
VETOED IT. AND ALSO IF YOU CAN
JUST ADDRESS WHY YOU THINK
THINGS HAVE CHANGED, I
UNDERSTAND, HE SAID IN HIS VETO
MESSAGE. HE ENCOURAGED THE
AUTHOR TO WORK WITH THE I G AND
THE BART BOARD TO RESOLVE THE
ISSUES. REGARDING REPRESENTED
EMPLOYEES BASICALLY SO JUST
CURIOUS ABOUT THAT. THANK YOU
THROUGH THE CHAIR. THANK YOU,
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR FOR YOUR
QUESTION. UM YOU KNOW, THE BILLS
ARE DIFFERENT FROM 22 TO THIS
BILL. UM. THERE WAS NO CRIMINAL
PENALTIES IN THE ORIGINAL BILL,
BUT THERE WAS SUBPOENA POWERS.
NOW I'M TAKING THE CRIMINAL
PENALTIES OUT OF THIS BILL, BUT
WE HAVEN'T RESOLVED THE SUBPOENA
POWER ISSUE. UM THERE WERE OTHER
ELEMENTS. THERE WAS WEINGARTEN
RIGHTS IN THE ORIGINAL BILL. I
THINK THE GOVERNOR AND HIS STAFF
UNFORTUNATELY, WE WEREN'T ABLE
TO SEE THAT BECAUSE IT ADDRESSES
SPECIFICALLY AS VETO MESSAGE AND
IT PROVIDES THAT I HAVE A NEW
FOR THE UNIONS TO PARTICIPATE AS
THE EMPLOYEE WISHES
NEVERTHELESS, THERE ARE SOME
OTHER DIFFERENCES. AND AS I
MENTIONED IN MY EARLIER
TESTIMONY RATHER THAN GO THROUGH
ALL THE ELEMENTS IN 20 TO 22
BILL OF WHAT WE'VE ADDED, I
DECIDED JUST TO MIRROR IT TO
WHAT WE DO FOR CALTRANS TO
CREATE SOME SIMPLICITY, AND I
HOPEFULLY SOME BROADER EMBRACE
FOR WHY WE'RE NOT TRYING TO DO
ANYTHING DIFFERENT, AND THAT'S
REALLY THE REFLECTIVE OF THE
OUTLINE OF WHAT YOU SEE IN FRONT
OF YOU TODAY WITH THE CHANGES
BEING THE CRIMINAL PENALTIES
BEING REMOVED FOR NOW, AS WE
CONTINUE THESE DISCUSSIONS AND
THE ASSERTION OF WEINGARTEN
RIGHTS, WHICH ARE NOT PART OF
THIS STATE LAWS THAT RELATES TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
ZIG, SO WE'RE ADDING THAT IN ITS
RESPONSIVE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
CONCERNS. OKAY SENATOR
ARCHULETTA TO SEYARTO. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. AND
CONGRATULATIONS FOR BRINGING ALL
THE ENTITIES TOGETHER. IF YOU
RECALL LAST YEAR, I DIDN'T VOTE
FOR IT. BUT THE WORD ON THE
STREET IS YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER LABORERS
ON BOARD. BART EVERYONE SEEMS TO
HAVE COME TOGETHER BECAUSE OF
YOUR LEADERSHIP. AND I APPLAUD
YOU FOR THAT. AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT'S STILL
PENDING. I FEEL VERY CONFIDENT.
YOU'LL WORK IT OUT. BY THE TIME
HE COMES BACK TO US, SO I WILL
NOT ONLY VOTE FOR IT, BUT I WILL
MOVE IT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
CIERTO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
I ALSO WANT TO CHIME IN WITH A
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THIS ISSUE
ON IT IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE, AND
IT'S DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF ALL
THE PLAYERS THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
THIS, BUT THE ONE PLAYER WE
HAVEN'T REALLY TALKED ABOUT IS
THE GENERAL PUBLIC BECAUSE THOSE
ARE THE PEOPLE THAT GET SHORT
CHANGED WHEN WE HIRE PEOPLE FOR
AN EXORBITANT AMOUNT OF MONEY.
TO FIX SOMETHING, AND THEN THEY
DON'T HAVE THE POWER TO FIX IT.
AND WHAT YOUR BILL DOES IS IT
ADDRESSES THESE DIFFERENT ISSUES
WITH THESE DIFFERENT ENTITIES
AND ALLOWS THE TO DO HIS JOB
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
HIRED TO DO IS MAKE SURE THAT
THE SERVICE THAT THE PEOPLE ARE
GETTING AH IS WHAT THEY ARE
PAYING FOR, AND ALSO THAT, YOU
KNOW, THERE'S NO CORRUPTION AND
ALL OF THOSE THINGS, AND THAT'S
WHAT THE PUBLIC WANTS. IT'S NOT
JUST WET, YOU KNOW THE UNION OR
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL OR WHOEVER
ELSE IT IS, ONCE IT'S WHAT THE
PUBLIC WANTS, AND I THINK YOU'VE
DONE A REALLY GOOD JOB OF KIND
OF MIRRORING ALL OF THOSE
TOGETHER INTO THIS BILL, SO I'LL
BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SEE IF
HOPEFULLY IT DOESN'T CHANGE A
WHOLE LOT. BUT IF THERE IS STUFF
THAT CONTINUES TO NEED WORK ON
GREAT, BUT PLEASE KEEP IN MIND
THAT YOU KNOW WE WANT HIM TO BE
EFFECTIVE AT THE END OF THE DAY.
SO THANK YOU. OKAY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. OKAY AGAIN. WANT TO
THANK YOU. I THINK YOU STRUCK A
REALLY GOOD BALANCE. OBVIOUSLY
YOU'VE KEPT THE PRESSURE ON
WHICH IS WHAT YOU WANTED TO DO
TO ENSURE THAT HAS BEEN
MENTIONED THAT BART WRITERS ARE
FEELING SAFE. THEY'RE FEELING
IT'S RELIABLE, BUT IT'S ALSO
ENSURING THAT THE FINANCIALS ARE
IN PLACE. MORE IMPORTANTLY, ALSO
SITTING DOWN WITH REPRESENTED
MEMBERS OF THE BART TO HEAR
THEIR CONCERNS AND ALSO WORK
WITH THEM. HOPEFULLY TO GET
TOWARDS THAT CHARTER THAT WE SAY
IS, IS 90% THERE, SO THAT IS THE
HOPE. THANK YOU FOR THAT,
SENATOR. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? JUST WANT TO SAY TWO
THINGS IN CLOSE ONE. FOR THE
RECORD. THE BART BOARD
REPRESENTATIVE RAISED TWO
ADDITIONAL ISSUES, BOTH OF WHICH
I'VE COMMITTED TO SATISFYING
COMPLETELY IN TERMS OF
CONFIDENTIALITY AND ACCESS TO
RECORDS, SO I WANT TO JUST MAKE
SURE THAT'S ON THE RECORD. AND
FINALLY FOR MANY OF US. I KNOW
MANY HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE, YOU
KNOW, INVESTMENT IN TRANSFER,
TRANSIT AND TRANS. IT'S REALLY,
REALLY IMPORTANT AND PEOPLE
WONDER WHY I END UP COMMENTING A
LOT ON PART, AND THAT'S REALLY
SIMPLY BECAUSE IT'S SO IMPORTANT
IN MY DISTRICT AND FROM MY
PEOPLE, NOT JUST FOR THEIR
ABILITY TO AN AFFORDABLE WAY TO
GET TO WORK INTO THEIR THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES. BUT WHAT'S
GOOD FOR THE ENVIRONMENT AND AS
WE TRY TO FIND WAYS TO INVEST IN
TRANSPORTATION, BECAUSE WE KNOW
WE NEED TO MAKE GREATER
INVESTMENTS. EVEN AT TIMES LIKE
BUDGET OF ISSUES THAT WE'RE
FACING TODAY THAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE THE CONFIDENCE FROM THE
PUBLIC THAT THE MONEY IS BEING
USED CORRECTLY, BECAUSE THAT'S
THE TRUST. THAT'S A PART OF ANY
KIND OF INVESTMENT THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO MAKE. AND SO THAT'S THE
WORK THAT WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
DO IN THIS AREA AGAIN. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR FOR HER WORK.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR ARCHULETTA.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 38278 MOTION IS DO PASS
AND RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS
GONZALEZ NILO HØI ALLEN. ALAN I.
ARCHULETTA TÔI BECKER BECKER I
BLAKE SPEAR. CORTESI. DOLLY
DOLLY! I DON LIMÓN BY NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I WENT SARTO HAMBURG.
WUHAN IRON. 11 0 11 0 LOOKS LIKE
THAT BILL IS OUT, BUT WE'LL KEEP
IT ON CALL. THANK YOU. REOPEN
THE ROLE FOR SB 827 REALLY
QUICKLY. SP 827. THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR RUNNING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING I SENATORS BLAKESPEAR
ORTEZ. DODD I WHEN I. 13 WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU SO
MUCH, SO WE'LL GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM TO WHICH IS SB 689 BY
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR WILL REOPEN
THE ROLE ON THAT ITEM, MADAM
SECRETARY. THANK THEM TOO. THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB 689
MOTION IS PASSED WITH THE CHAIR,
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING NO
SENATORS. BECKER. ORTEZ E DOLLY!
NEWMAN WHEN SARTO SEROTONIN
HAMBURG, WUHAN, WE'LL HAVE I DID
GET UMBERG HI. I'M VERY GOOD.
ALRIGHT OKAY, LET'S REOPEN THAT
ROLE. THAT'S OKAY. WE HAVE
MEMBERS, ADDING ON FILE ITEM
TWO. SB 689, PLEASE. MOTION IS
DO PASS. CORTESI DOLLY! NEWMAN
AYE. AND THE OTHER ONE AND
WAHABI WAS I EXPERIENCE. THREE,
OKAY? 10 TO 3 WILL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TO ADD ON UNTIL WE NEED TO. WE
DON'T KNOW. EVERYBODY ELSE WE'RE
STILL WAITING FOR. OKAY. WRONG
REFERRAL.
OKAY WE'LL GO BACK TO FILE ITEM.
THREE. SB 827 WITH DO PASS TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. SENATOR
GLASER'S BILL, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? MADAM SECRETARY,
THIS FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
827. GOT EMOTION. ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB 827. THE MOTION IS DUE
PAST AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR. VOTING I
CENTERS LIKE SPEAR, ORTEZ E I E.
I. OKAY 15 0. THAT BILL IS OUT.
AND WE'LL MOVE BACK UP TO FILE
ITEM TO SP 689 SENATOR BLAKE
SPEAR. SHE PASSED TOO FAST. THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB 689.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS WITH THE
CHAIR. VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SENATORS CORTESI
DOLLY! YOU GOTTA SIGN. KIND OF
THREE. YEAH. OR TASTY. I SEE. I
OKAY. 11-3. THAT BILL IS OUT.
11-3 THANK YOU. ALRIGHT, THAT
CONCLUDES OUR SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. WE ARE
IN A DERMOTT. THANK YOU.